-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
I'm so happy to have the studio
audience back.
The energy is great
and honestly --
-Hey, hey, Seth?
A-Are we allowed to give tickets
to friends again?
-Very sorry,
that's one of my very rude
writers, Mike Scollins,
everybody.
-Uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah,
now that we have audiences back,
a friend wants to come in June.
-You're asking me about June?
-Yeah, do you know who the
guests are that night?
-Seven months from now?
-I know it's far out,
I just need to make sure
it's not a current
or former President.
Or Vice President.
Or member of Congress. Or other
senior administration official.
-What?
-And just to be safe,
not Jodie Foster.
[ Laughter ]
-Scollins, who did you get
tickets for?
-John Hinckley Jr.
-Are you serious?!
-Oh, oh it's not the John
Hinckley Jr. you're thinking of.
-Oh, it's not the one who tried
to assassinate Ronald Reagan?
-Oh, okay no it is the John
Hinckley Jr. you're thinking of.
-Why would you invite him to the
show next year?!
-Well, he can't come now,
he's committed.
But, he's fully getting out
in June.
-And you think it'd be
appropriate to have
John Hinckley Jr.
in the audience?
-Would you rather him as a
guest?
I don't know how his anecdotes
are gonna be.
Hasn't really done much lately.
-I don't want him here at al--
How do you even know him?
-How do you even know
Terry Gross? I don't know.
You just meet people.
-I'm sorry, Scollins,
but John Hinckley Jr.'s
not invited here.
-[ Inhales sharply ]
Seth, it's like the judge said,
if he hadn't tried to
kill the President, he would've
been unconditionally released
a long, long, long time ago!
-The judge did not say that.
-The judge said exactly that.
-Oh, boy.
[ Light laughter ]
-You're the one who said
you're excited to have
an audience back.
Is John Hinckley Jr. not "woke"
enough for your liberal agenda?
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly no.
Wait, actually, what are
John Hinckley's politics?
-I'm actually not sure.
He's, like, weirdly a-political
for a presidential assassin.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He weirdly is.
Why is he even being released?
-Well, his therapist is retiring
in January, so.
-That can't be true.
Wow.
Still, I'm sorry, Scollins, I
don't want your friend,
John Hinckley Jr. in the studio.
-Alright. I'll tell him, but,
heads up,
he doesn't handle
disappointment well.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you gonna get me killed?
-Guess it depends on how
Jodie Foster feels about you.
-Get outta here!